my way we have our man my my my my my my
my my my my hey guys merry here with our
first story manhunt and bully were
released surprisingly on ps4 this week
bully and manhunt to rock star classics
from the playstation 2 era have been
unexpectedly released on the ps4 this
week both titles upscale to 1080p and
both have been retrofitted with trophy
support they can both be downloaded for
15 bucks a piece originally released in
2006 bully casts players as Jimmy
Hopkins a teenage miscreant that has
been dumped by parents and Bulworth
Academy a school ruled by clicks and
corrupt teachers Jimmy must overcome the
trials and tribulations of high school
to rise the top of the food chain
manhunt meanwhile was released in 2003
and in the years following was the
subject of much controversy the Rockstar
North developed title mixed the
psychological thriller genre with
stealth action horror you can get those
now one of the biggest stories this week
was that Microsoft had an open
invitation to unite online networks that
means that ps4 players could play with
Xbox one player finally well it's out
and Sony responded kind of Sony issued
an encouraging but indecisive response
to Microsoft's invitation to unite the
online networks of ps4 and Xbox one
within certain games on Monday Microsoft
publicly invited other platform holders
to allow the same games to be played
online across different console networks
this awesome proposal could bring an end
to more of a decade of segregation
between ps4 and Xbox Sony's response
issued to gamespot suggested the
market-leading platform holder remains
open minded about cross console play but
stopped short of discussing a deal with
Xbox Live so you're saying there's a
chance PlayStation has been supporting
cross-platform play between PC on
several software titles starting with
final fantasy 11 on ps2 and PC back in
2002 we'd be happy to have a
conversation with the publishers or
developers who are interested in
cross-platform play Sony's response was
to a direct question about whether or
not it would be interested in working
with Microsoft it's not a yes it's a
solid maybe
as if rocket League developer psionics
wasn't cool enough already they actually
talked about combining ps4 and Xbox one
online and they said it was super
technically possible rocket League
developer psionic Studios has discussed
becoming the first game to support
cross-network multiplayer between Xbox
one and ps4 saying it has already
figured out the technology necessary to
bridge the two communities speaking in
an interview with gamespot psionics vice
president Jeremy Dunham said the only
thing left to work out was the politics
and then it's full steam ahead to finish
the solution we've already started he
said technologically everything works
we've got to figure it out just a little
bit of time to get everything up and
running right now excitement is the best
way to put it we just want to get it in
there and make it happen next up if you
like gossip and rumors you're in luck
ps4 k was rumored to be true and it is
reports that Sony is working on a more
powerful ps4 are true according to
digital foundry publication states it is
independently verified a report
published on March 18th which said the
new version of the console will have an
upgraded GPU according to the site
Sony's R&D labs have prototyped the
device which more than one source has
referred to as the PlayStation 4 K it
continues however to explain that
although the hardware offers more
graphics processing power it's not
enough to deliver a robust 4k gaming
experience digital foundry states that
although the machine may be capable of
playing high-definition media and some
technical aspects of 4k spec gaming such
as high dynamic range the hardware
upgrade isn't currently significant
enough to constitute a full step into 4k
gaming finally two new Xbox backwards
compatibility games will release this
week two more xbox 360 games have been
added to the Xbox one backwards
compatibility library the games arrive
in a lineup on the same day that the
Xbox one was updated to include a new
store where you can search for buy and
download backwards compatible xbox 360
games the games you asked why it's the
original Dark Souls and tekken tag
tournament 2 which i like to call ticket
agency as announced previously anyone
who orders a digital copy of Dark Souls
3 for xbox one gets a free copy of dark
Seoul's xbox 360 version playable
through backwards compatibility there's
no set schedule for when new games will
be added as microsoft said previously
titles are added as soon as they're
ready not on a monthly basis we marry
miss remember me my family they pick me
you